how did you get to the humor of this did
you earn it have you always had a sense
of humor with well with the title
specifically I always knew that I wanted
it to be called I'm glad my mom died I
wanted something that would be really
bold and attention grabbing and
hopefully that people with a sense of
humor would get you know uh and also I
think anybody with who's experienced
parental abuse understands and I I
didn't feel so concerned with I knew
there would be you know some people who
are like I don't get that title but I
thought that'd be that'd be totally fine
and when people maybe don't get the the
comedy and the tone how do they behave
and what how does it make you feel um I
think that anything worth saying is
probably going to be divisive I think if
it's not divisive it probably there's
probably no new conversation to be had
there so I I felt it was an important
and worthwhile title